radical trumpist republican member of  Congress Madison cawthorne on the floor  of the House of Representatives said  that as far as he's concerned you're a  woman if you have two X chromosomes and  no tallywacker I'm about to Define what  a woman is for you XX chromosomes no  tallywacker it's so simple for all  intents and purposes when we talk about  a woman it's not unreasonable to think  of a woman as someone who lives as a  woman  sees themselves as a woman and is seen  as a Woman by Society it's not a perfect  definition but it goes to the question  that lots of these dishonest  right-wingers are trying to get to which  is how should a Court decide whether  somebody could be discriminated against  for their real or perceived gender